هذه الاتفاقية الأجنبية في 21 تشرين الثاني (نوفمبر) ،
إنها
تسوية
وسط كلاسيكية حيث ليس لدينا
فائز ربما يكون لدينا
خاسرون فقط بعد هذا الشهر من الأزمة في
السودان ،
وأنا أعلم أن الكثير من الناس
يرفضونها وأنا أعلم أنه حتى أولئك الذين
وقعوا عليها هم  لست سعيدًا بكل
التفاصيل ولست سعيدًا
بالاتفاق ،
فنحن كأمم متحدة
ما زلنا
نرحب بها من ناحيتين رحبنا بها
وأرحب بها شخصيًا
كخطوة  المزيد من إراقة الدماء في البلاد
وربما
التشرذم الخطير
الذي قد يؤدي إلى تطورات كما
رأيناها في دول أخرى في
ليبيا وسوريا أو اليمن ، وأرى أيضًا
أنها خطوة
نحو استعادة النظام الدستوري
، فهي ليست استعادة
للدستور.  النظام ولكنه خطوة
نحو استعادة
النظام الدستوري في السودان
وثانيًا أرى أنه
فرصة كفرصة لإعادة
التركيز على جميع القضايا الخلافية.
ues
في السودان التي كانت هناك قبل 21
سبتمبر وقبل 25
أكتوبر وتحتاج للمناقشة كفرصة
أه للعودة إلى حوار وطني جاد
حول جميع القضايا التي تحتاج
إلى التعامل معها وأيضًا للحصول على
الدعم الدولي  إلى السودان
جيدًا ii ليس لدي
تحفظات على وثيقة
كان السودانيون قد وافقوا عليها
أو وافق عليها بعض أصحاب المصلحة السودانيين
أه بالنسبة لي الشيء المهم
هو
هل سيتم ترجمتها بالفعل إلى
حقيقة واقعة وأصحاب المصلحة هنا أو
الممثلون سيكونون  يتم الحكم محليًا
ودوليًا من
خلال طريقة تنفيذها على سبيل المثال
وأين نحن في يوم يكون فيه يوم لدينا فيه
مظاهرات بالخارج ضد جديد
أه حيث لدينا احتجاجات بالخارج حتى
ضد الاتفاق سوف يفعل الناس
المحتجين على الاتفاقية
يُسمح لهم بالتظاهر والاحتجاج
السلمي
دون التعرض للقمع
بالقوة المفرطة التي تُستخدم ضدهم بالقوة المفرطة
يتم الإفراج عن جميع المعتقلين لأن
الاتفاقية
تقول إن هذه إجراءات واضحة
داخل
الاتفاقية وأعتقد أن كل من سيحكم
على الاتفاقية سيحكم في المقام الأول
على تنفيذ
الاتفاقية سيكون لرئيس الوزراء
الحرية
في ذلك.  تشكيل حكومته ،
إنه سؤال حاسم للغاية أو هل سيكون
لدينا تدخلات هنا من أطراف أخرى ،
لذا لا يتعلق الأمر كثيرًا بوجود
سطر آخر في الاتفاقية بالإضافة إلى
سؤال
هل سيتم تنفيذه ،
لقد رأينا
تفسيرات مختلفة لم تكن
مقنعة حقًا بشأنه.  في
الأسبوعين الماضيين ، علمنا أن
المظاهرات تسوء في بعض الأحيان
وأن السيطرة على المظاهرات تسوء
، وكان لدينا ذلك قبل
استخدام الغاز المسيل للدموع بشكل
مفرط ربما أو
حتى
بطريقة اعتقدت الشرطة أنها
الشيء الصحيح الذي تعرض له الناس.  بواسطة
عبوات الغاز المسيل للدموع لكننا حصلنا عليها
للمرة الأولى وآمل بشدة
لآخر مرة في السودان منذ الانتقال
ب  على سبيل المثال ، تم استخدام الذخيرة الحية
ضد المتظاهرين على نطاق واسع
بعد إحدى هذه الاحتجاجات ، حيث أصيب 100
شخص بجروح ،
وقتلنا حوالي 15 شخصًا في ذلك اليوم
وأصيب 100 شخص بالرصاص ، وهذه
ليست
طريقة حضارية
لحماية مواطنيك.  ليست
طريقة حضارية للسيطرة الصحيحة حتى لو
أه حتى لو كان بعض المتظاهرين على
الأرجح يضغطون ضد الشرطة أو حتى
إذا كان بعض المتظاهرين لا أعرف ما إذا
كان ذلك قد استخدم زجاجات مولوتوف ،
فأنت لا تستخدم
الذخيرة الحية على نطاق واسع
التحكم
في عرض توضيحي
جيدًا لما فعلته
منذ البداية في
الواقع قبل 25 أكتوبر / تشرين الأول ، علمنا
بوجود أزمة ، لذلك كنت
أتنقل بين
القادة المدنيين والقادة العسكريين
وقادة المجتمع المدني و FFC
وآخرين حتى قبل 25 أكتوبر / تشرين الأول.  كان
الأمر أكثر أهمية بعد 25 أكتوبر
للتنقل بين القادة المختلفين
للاستماع إليهم لمعرفة ما
هي المشاكل لتطوير أفكار حول
ذلك  على المستوى لا أسميها وساطة ،
لكن انتهى بنا المطاف في تسهيل
الوساطة ، أحد الأسئلة الأولى التي طرحتها على
كل من
الجنرال برهان ورئيس الوزراء حمدوك
بعد 25 أكتوبر هو هل تقبل
أن يتم إنشاء لجنة شخص حكيم
ويمكننا المساعدة في ذلك.
إنشائها من أجل حل
الأسئلة والمشاكل واتفق كلاهما
بسرعة كبيرة جدًا وبعد
ذلك بالطبع لم يكن هناك واحد فقط لكل
لجنة من الحكماء ،
كان هناك زوجان كان هناك
مبادرتان للوساطة حاولنا التنسيق
معهم  لا تنسق معهم بل نسق
معهم
من أجل
طرح أفكار جيدة على
الطاولة وربما تجذبهم ونحن
بالطبع ننسقها مع
المجتمع الإقليمي والدولي ومع أه
الوسطاء أو المحاورين الإقليميين والدوليين
الذين أتوا إلى البلاد
لذلك  بقينا على اتصال مع كل من
القيادة المدنية والعسكرية
طوال هذه الأسابيع الأربعة ولكن
الاتفاق كان  في النهاية التي وقع
عليها الجنرال
برهان ورئيس الوزراء حمدوك كانت اتفاقية سودانية بالكامل
لم
نقم بصياغتها ولم نقم بإعطاء أي نصيحة مفصلة
حول
لا أعرف ما إذا كنت منحازًا
لاختيار طرف واحد أم لا.  الآخر ولكن
أعتقد أن كلا الجانبين يعتقد أحيانًا
أنني متحيز تجاه الجانب الآخر
وإذا قرأت
تعليقات على نشاطي ووسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
أه الآن أتلقى الكثير من النيران من
جهات مختلفة أولئك
الذين أعتقد أنهم أقرب إلى الجيش
جانب وأقول كلما تحدثت عن
حقوق الإنسان في هذا البلد أن هذا
تدخل غير مرحب به أو
تدخلاً في الشؤون الداخلية
وأولئك الأقرب إلى الاتحاد أو
لجان المقاومة
الذين يقولون إنني ما كان يجب أن أرحب
بالاتفاق بين الجنرال روهان
وهاندوك.  لذلك أعتقد أنه من
الطبيعي أن يستمع
ممثل الأمين العام للأمم المتحدة
إلى جميع الأطراف وأيضًا الحصول على
النار من جميع الأطراف إذا حاول
المرء الحفاظ على
عدم التحيز هنا
نحن متحيزون إذا كنت ترغب في ذلك ، فنحن
منحازون لمبادئنا وقيمنا
التي تمثل حقوق الإنسان في
مقدمة حقوق الإنسان أولًا عن سيادة القانون
، ونحن متحيزون إذا كنت
تريد استخدام هذه الكلمة في الاتفاقيات
التي وافق عليها السودانيون أنفسهم
في الماضي ، وهو
إعلان دستوري واتفاقية جوبا
للسلام ، نحن هنا للمساعدة في
تنفيذ ذلك ، هل لدي علاقات
جيدة مع الجيش ، نعم ، كنت
هناك أشخاصًا
ينتقدون حضور أحاديات
في الجيش أو خارج
الجيش  بالتأكيد نعتقد
أننا قمنا بالكثير من العمل
من أجل إقناع كلا الجانبين العسكري
والمدني بأننا هنا من
أجل كل السودان ربما لم
نقنع الجميع ولكن آمل أن نكون قد
أقنعنا نفسه ،
نعم ، هناك  الكثير من
المطالب أو الاقتراحات خاصة
عبر وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي التي
تقول فودكا ماذا تفعل أنت
تتحدث فقط لا يجب أن تأتي ويجب عليك
فرض عقوبات على الأفراد
في السودان أو يجب عليك الانتقال إلى الفصل
السابع
للأسف وراء هذه المطالب ،
هناك الكثير من سوء الفهم حول
ما يمكن أن تفعله
الأمم المتحدة وما
يمكن أن تفعله البعثة السياسية للأمم المتحدة في السودان
للمبتدئين ، أود أن أقول إن لدينا
تفويضًا يأتي من مجلس الأمن
ونحن نعمل على
أساس هذا
التفويض الذي هو في
الأصل قرار مجلس الأمن
25 24 لعام
2020 وهذه ولاية الفصل 6
وبالطبع أنا بصفتي الممثل
الخاص للأمين العام
وكرئيس لشروط الوحدة لا يمكنني تغييرها.  تفويضاتي الخاصة
هي مجلس أمن
يمكنه تغيير التفويض ، كما هو الحال بالنسبة
للعقوبات ، ويمكن للدول القومية الفردية
فرض عقوبات ويفعلون
ذلك
، ويمكن لمجلس الأمن ، إذا كان موحدًا ،
تحسين العقوبات ولكن
ممثل الأمين العام
أو البعثة  في السودان ، لا يمكننا
الاستمرار في فعل شيء ما ،
لكن ما نقوم به في الأساس هو من خلال
كلماتنا هو أن النصيحة هي أن الدعوة
هي  اقتراحات وأفكار ،
هناك الكثير من الدعم الفني
الكثير من الدعم الفني أو اللوجستي
ولكن هذا يصل
إلى 99 من خلال فريق الأمم المتحدة القطري من
خلال وكالات وصناديق
وبرامج الأمم المتحدة
التي تعمل هنا UNDP and UNICEF World
health Organization والعديد من
ولأننا هنا وهذا قرار
من مجلس الأمن كمهمة متكاملة
فهذا يعني أننا ننسق
وندمج مع هذه البرامج
والصناديق والوكالات التابعة للأمم المتحدة
بحيث يكون ما تسمونه
الدعم اللوجستي أو الدعم الفني
بحيث  يتماشى مع ولاياتنا حيث
بدأنا نود دعم
وزارة العدل في
صياغة قانون مفوضية
الانتخابات والخطوة التالية هي قانون
الانتخابات الانتخابات مهمة للغاية فهي
ليست ناجحة
بشكل جيد ما الذي يفعله أه
الجدول الزمني  لا يزال يتعين مناقشته ،
كان من المفترض أن يكون بحلول نهاية عام
2023 بنهاية عام 2024 أو أوائل عام
2024 وبنهاية فترة النقل.
يبدو أن هناك قرارًا الآن
حيث
يتفق رئيس الوزراء ورئيس مجلس السيادة على أنه
يجب تقديمه قليلاً
ليحب يوليو 2023 والذي من شأنه أن يمنحنا
أكثر من عام ونصف بقليل
وهذا ممكن تقنيًا من الناحية
السياسية  من الطموح
للغاية التحضير
لانتخابات حرة ونزيهة وذات مصداقية في
غضون عام ونصف كما قلت من الناحية الفنية
، من الممكن أنها تحتاج إلى الكثير من
حسن النية وحسن النية من كل من
ينفذها ، فهي تحتاج إلى قانونين
تحتاجهما الأحزاب للحصول عليها
من
المحتمل أولاً أن يتم
تأسيس عملهم معًا لخطوة بعض الأحزاب ، فهم مجرد حركات أو
مجرد مجموعات من
ممثلي المجتمع المدني الذين قد يرغبون في
تشكيل حزب ويجب أن يكون
لديهم مؤتمرات حزبية عليهم تطوير
برنامج لديهم
لتقديم مرشحين ، يجب
تدريبهم وهو أمر جيد جدًا للأمم المتحدة في
تدريبه ، وخاصة الشابات
اللائي يرغبن في الترشح للانتخابات ، لذا من
الناحية الفنية  عام ونصف
ممكن سياسيًا ، فهو يحتاج إلى
الكثير من الطاقة والكثير من حسن
النية وحسن النية
[موسيقى]
حسنًا ، ربما لا تراها ولكن هذا
لا يعني أنها غير موجودة أه
لقد كنا كما قلت أه نشيطين للغاية
مع الوسيط الجنوبي السوداني
في المفاوضات في جوبا
هذا الصيف بين جزيرة عبد الله
، مرحبا والحكومة الآن نعلم
أنها تعثرت وتعثرت جزئيًا لأن
دعني أرى انعدام الثقة
وأنا  أعتقد أن قضية الثقة أصبحت
أكثر صعوبة بعد
أحداث الشهر الماضي ،
الأمر نفسه ينطبق على أبراهام
[موسيقى]
لأنه لم يكن مستعدًا للانضمام إلى
المفاوضات في عملية التفاوض في
الصيف ، كان لديه مواقفه الخاصة.
ليس من المفترض أن
يناقش أنه يمكنه فعل ذلك بشكل أفضل مما
أفعله ولست متأكدًا من أنه سيكون أسهل الآن
نحن بحاجة إلى اثنين من
تدابير بناء الثقة ويمكننا
أن نجعلها متاحة هناك لهذا اليوم أعني
أننا نرى ذلك  الناس يقتلون
ه  يومًا ما في دلفي ، إذا كنت تريد البدء في
بناء الثقة ، فعلينا تنفيذ
الترتيبات الأمنية بموجب اتفاقية جوبا
للسلام
الآن ، فأنا أعني أحيانًا أننا
ركزنا بشدة
على الأحداث في الرسوم المتحركة
أه
أننا نعني المجتمع الدولي
ولكنني  قد يقول أيضًا مع الاحترام الواجب أن
أجزاء من المجتمع السوداني
لم تنتبه لما حدث
في الأسابيع الأربعة الماضية فيما يتعلق
بالصراعات الطائفية المُسيَّسة وهناك
طوائف يسميها بعض الناس
قبليين لكنهم  دائمًا ما يكون لديهم بعد سياسي
ولديهم بعد قوي
من مجرمي الإجرام المحض الذين
يحاولون استغلال الوضع
ضعف أجهزة إنفاذ
القانون وبالتالي ربما أيضًا أن
العديد من الفاعلين الذين يجب أن يوفروا
الأمن في دارفور كانوا في الواقع أه
منخرطون ومشغولون هنا  كاترينا
إذا أردنا بناء الثقة
لاستعادتها وربطها بسؤالك الأول ،
فماذا عن عربة التفاح؟  نحن
ندخل في مفاوضات أه سلام أو
بعد كسالى أو مرحبًا باستئنافها
، يحتاج الأمر إلى بناء ثقة في هذا
البلد حتى يتسنى حتى للفاعلين الذين
نريد الانضمام إليهم والذين لم يوقعوا على
اتفاقية السلام الوظيفية أن يروا اتفاقية جوبا
للسلام  على الأقل يتم
تنفيذه بالكامل
بشكل جيد ، هناك
أكثر من جيش واحد ، أعني أننا رأينا
القوات المسلحة السودانية التي هي جيش نظامي
ولكن لدينا أيضًا
جيدًا ، فأنا أفقد أحيانًا عدد أربعة خمسة
ستة سبعة
منظمات أو جيوش مسلحة أخرى مختلفة
كما أقول أحيانًا و  إذا كان لديك
ثلاثة أربعة وخمسة وستة وسبعة جيوش في
بلد ما ، فمن
المستحيل
توفير
الاستقرار لهم ،
واعلم أنه
يجب أن يكون لديك قوة فنية نظامية
واحدة تحت
قيادة واحدة وكيف يمكنك بناؤها نعم
يمكنك دمج مجموعات
الكفاح المسلح بطريقة أو بأخرى ،
هناك الكثير من المفاوضات
التي يجب إجراؤها ويجب أن تكون هناك تغييرات كبيرة في
الهياكل ليس
فقط لنفسك ولكن بالتأكيد من
المجموعة الفنية  يجب عليك إجراء
مناقشة حول ذلك ونحن نسميها
إصلاح قطاع الأمن أو الإصلاح العسكري
الذي لا يضعف القوات المسلحة
فعليًا لتقوية القوات المسلحة
يجعلهم مسؤولين بالتنسيق
مع المدنيين حول ما
تحتاجه جيشًا لأني أقصد  أنت بحاجة إلى خمس
ست وسبع مجموعات مسلحة
بأسلحتهم الخاصة ،
وسياراتهم الخاصة ، وبنادقهم الخاصة ،
ويتعين عليهم التنسيق
في المؤسسات التي يتعين عليك
إنشاؤها لتنسيقها أو
لن يكون من الأفضل كثيرًا إذا كانت بعض
هذه المجموعات  سيشكل بعض الأشياء
لمجرد اقتراح مجرد اقتراح مجرد
فكرة عما
يمكن أن يشكل شيئًا مثل
الحرس الوطني في الولايات المتحدة أو
في بعض البلدان الأخرى حيث
لديك قوة يتم تجنيدها محليًا
ويمكن أن تتدخل إذا كانت هناك
مشاكل
في  الموقع الذي يعيشون فيه ولكن بعد
ذلك سيكونون
جزءًا من جيش واحد
مشترك
أو قوة مسلحة
تحت
قيادة مدنية بالطبع مع قيادة عسكرية
ولكن تحت سيطرة البوليس.  القيادة الفنية
لحكومة مدنية
أعتقد أنه سيكون في مصلحة
السودان ولا أعتقد أن هناك الكثير
من الخلاف بيني هنا وبين
الجنرالات السودانيين الذين
تعلمون أننا شاركنا
بشكل مكثف في
المفاوضات قبل
الاستيلاء العسكري على السلطة  25 أكتوبر
ومحاولة المساعدة في حل
هذه المشكلة مع أه
مع الشرق وأم أنا
أفهم أن مؤتمر باجا
قد منح أصحاب المصلحة هنا
وقتًا أطول قليلاً الآن من
ديسمبر ويقولون إنهم
سيعطونهم آخر  أشهر حتى لو
كانت شهرين الآن حتى نحتاج إلى
قرار ، فهذا يعني أن المفاوضات يجب
أن تستأنف قريبًا جدًا لا أفكر
شخصيًا ولكن هذا الأمر متروك
للسودانيين لمعرفة بعضهم
البعض وربما مع بعض التسهيلات من
الدولية  الجهات الفاعلة مثلنا أو
غيرنا لا أعتقد أن
إلغاء مسار واحد
سيكون حلاً لأن ما
نحتاجه هو مناقشة
أو حوار شامل للغاية  فيما يتعلق بما تحتاجه السهولة
من حيث التمثيل ،
فإن الشرق سياسيًا أو كان ممثلًا
تمثيلا ناقصًا سياسيًا ، أعتقد
أنه لا يوجد الكثير من الشك حول ذلك ،
وأود أن أقول على الأقل بنفس القدر من الأهمية أو
ربما الأهم من ذلك السؤال
حول
كيفية تحقيق التنمية المستدامة
في  الشرق
وهذه مسألة موارد ، لذا لدينا
تمثيل ولدينا موارد مادية ،
هذه الأسئلة يجب أن يتم تسويتها
بالخارج